Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
in which experts from
our Latin American communities
will teach you
how to use our tools,
developer products,
APIs and new tricks.
I'm glad to inaugurate this
Google Developers Hackademy
with a course created
and presented by Antonio Guzman,
organizer of the GDG
Androidtitlan in Mexico.
This course consists
of five parts.
We invite you to watch it
and learn with us.
Let's begin.
Hello, my name is
Antonio Guzman.
Welcome to this
introduction course
to Google Apps Script.
In this course,
our goal is to get you closer
to the Google Apps Script
concept,
knowing the necessary elements
to start working,
knowing the services available,
and giving examples
with some programming.
We'll work with Spreadsheet,
Document
and we'll integrate the Gmail
e-mail sending service.
In this first lesson,
we'll talk about 3 things:
what is Google Apps Script,
what is needed to build
our own scripts,
and which are the services
available in the platform.
Throughout the lesson
we'll do an exercise,
and when we finish,
we'll understand the concept
of Google Apps Script
and we'll be able
to execute our own scripts.
In business and personal
environments,
Google Apps allow us
to store, generate
and transform information,
but we don't always persist it.
This is where Google Apps Script
gives us the chance
to maximize the value
of our information
because we can exploit it
in a simple way.
Some of the services we use
every day
have APIs, which, using
the JavaScript syntax,
allow us to write programs
to do all kinds of things
that range from something
as simple as extracting
the number of unread e-mails,
to more elaborated ones,
like translating the information
of a spreadsheet,
sending it to another document,
and then attaching it
to an e-mail
we're sending through Gmail.
There are several services
available in Google Apps Script
and they're divided
into two categories:
the first category is called
Google Apps Services,
which includes Calendar,
Contacts,
Dodlist,
Document, Domain,
Drive, Finance,
Forms,
Gmail,
Groups,
Language,
Maps,
Sites,
Spreadsheet...
And well, the other group
is the advanced services one.
In this group we have:
Adsense,
Analytics,
Bigquery,
Prediction,
Task and Urlshortener.
頻hich ones have you used?
In this case,
though we're writing
JavaScript programs,
they're neither run
on the client's side
nor executed in the browser.
These programs run
on the server's side,
but we don't need to configure
a specialized server either,
they run on Google's
infrastructure,
they run on Google's servers.
So, to start the development
of Google Apps Script
we need to visit
the developers' site.
There, we'll find a section
devoted to App Script
and we need to see the site
as an initial info source,
since there we'll find
the definition for App Script,
the basic and intermediate
tutorials,
the documentation
for the services available
in the platform,
and it also works
as an access route
to the Code Editor,
where we will start
writing our programs.
And now it's time
to start programming.
LET'S GET TO WORK
Click on the center red button,
"Start scripting,"
to redirect you
to scriptgoogle.com.
We see a welcome window.
The welcome window
has different elements
which are templates
to create scripts,
tutorials and the scripts
we've recently created.
We're going to choose
an empty option, Blank Project.
When on the Editor screen,
the first thing to do
is name the project.
We will name this one "gas01."
We click on OK
and we continue
building our script
and getting familiarized
with our environment.
Notice that we have
several menu options
that facilitate the programming.
We can see the Log,
access the Help,
publish the function list
we have,
and, well, we now have
a function skeleton.
Let's declare our variable,
to which a document
we'll create will be associated.
In order to create
the document, we will use
the "DocumentApp" class.
The DocumentApp class
is part of the APIs that,
as we mentioned before,
allow us to use the services
available in the platform.
DocumentApp has a method
called "create".
This method receives
a text chain
that is the name
for the document
we want to create.
This document is created
into our Google Drive unit.
We'll give it a name similar
to the one of our script:
"gas -01."
Now, what we're going to do
is putting text
in our document.
For this, we get its body
and it's there where
we will paste the text.
We use a method called
"appendParagraph,"
which needs us to give it
a text chain,
which in this case will be:
"Welcome
to the world of scripts,"
and this way we already have
a paragraph in our document;
it exists and has a content.
It'd also be good
to add a second paragraph to it
to keep adding content.
Then, how do we do that?
Just as we did it before.
Document,
we get this object's body
and once again, the method
is the same: appendParagraph,
but now we will change
the text, all right?
Would you like it
if it now says:
"Welcome to the world
of Google Apps Script?"
Remember, the method
gets a text chain
which is "Welcome to the world
of Google Apps Script."
Semicolon, we finish
our sentence...
Now we save it
and we run our script
for the first time.
In the upper bar we see
it is running
and it asks something.
Every script we run
needs the user's authorization.
So we give it to it.
It lets us know
which are the permissions
this script has.
It says it'll access our unit,
so we click on "OK"
and we already know
what our script needs:
accessing our Drive.
We create a document in Drive,
so we enter:
drive.google.com.
We search our document.
Do you remember its name?
"gas -01,"
and then it opens it.
And there's the text
we had written:
"Welcome to the world
of scripts."
of Google Apps Scripts,"
and our script worked,
it did what we asked it to do.
The scenarios, problems
and opportunities we have
are very diverse.
That's why,
when we build a script,
we have to consider
all the services available
to reach the best
possible solution.
Each one of these services,
as we saw it,
has its own APIs.
We'll have to use them
to reach that solution.
So we can state
that Google Apps Script
is not a way or a recipe,
but the possibility to choose
several items
to reach a solution.
RECAP
Before starting our next lesson,
I recommend you keep
getting familiarized
with the resources available
in the developers' site.
Let's remember
we have the APIs there
for the different services
available.
Check them out,
why not choose those
that correspond
to the services you use more.
Perhaps Calendar, Gmail,
Spreadsheet, Drive...
When you start seeing
the API's methods
and you'll certainly come up
with things you can do
for the next scripts
you are trying.
You'll be able to ....
scenarios, solutions,
and well, now it's time
to getting familiarized
with the editor.
We saw it has several menus
and each menu,
several options.
Start clicking here and there.
You also have to remember
what we did in the beginning:
clicking on "Start scripting"
in the developers' site.
Next time, when you want
to build a script,
you don't need to do it
from there,
you'll be able to do it
from Google Drive,
where an option to create
script-like documents
has been added, and that's it,
you'll have started building
scripts from Google Drive.
This is it for our first lesson.
In the next lesson we'll see
the different types of scripts
and we will try
two execution modes:
the manual and the
time-triggered executions.
See you next time.
Keep on programming.